et puis il ya une autre liste qui a deux
sièges aussi qu'ils nous posent plus de
difficultés qui est la liste de
jean-pierre avance alors qui compte tenu
des pratiques qu'elle a eue pendant la
campagne se trouve un peu en
contradiction avec les échanges qu'on a
eu au cours du mois de juillet sur la
moralisation de la vie politique
de quoi parlez vous de quelle pratique
parler vos jeux jeux de la manière dont
on aborde et dont on fait en sorte que
les motive les électeurs pour voter on a
vu des pratiques pour les français de
l'étranger cette fois ci pour une liste
qui a des élus qui aujourd'hui me pose
problème
jungle comme ce sont des accusations
graves que vous proférez est-ce que vous
avez des preuves
je pense qu'il faudra que oui
effectivement on apporte un certain
nombre d'éléments a pour eux au moment
des recours et au moment des ddd au
procureur sur sur ce qui s'est passé
effectivement au cours de ces élections
j'arrive le compte vous accuser un
candidat d'avoir acheté des voix
j'accuse influencer une élection j'ai
constaté au vu même de chiffres qui ont
été publiés que l'on peut avoir de très
gros doutes sur le financement de la
campagne d'un candidat qui aujourd'hui à
deux élus pour les français de
l'étranger et sur la manière dont le
parti politique qui a soutenu sa
campagne sert l'association solidaire
des français de l'étranger et financé
reçoit des dons et je crois qu'il faudra
effectivement que nous regardons ça de
plus près ce qu'elle suit c'est vraiment
j'allais dire tout en étant heureux de
7,2 de ma réélection je prend finalement
comme un outrage la manière dont la
campagne s'est déroulée et le résultat
de ce vote
quelle suite allez-vous donner très
clairement à cette affaire est ce que
vous envisagez des poursuites
judiciaires
moi j'ai pas à envisager des poursuites
judiciaires mais je vais regarder dès
demain quelle est la meilleure manière
de faire prospérer les informations dont
je dispose de manière à ce que ceux qui
sont en mesure d'évaluer si les
accusations que je porte doit avoir des
suites et les observations qu'on a faits
doivent être de suite puisse
effectivement poursuivre parce que à mon
sens sur le plan moral ce qu'on a vu
n'est pas acceptable
j'arrive le compte vous aller contester
cette élection je ne pense pas
nécessairement que ce soit du domaine de
la contestation de l'élection
je pense qu'il s'agit du respect des
règles de comptabilité des partis
politiques de détournement d'un certain
nombre de règles et moi je l'observent
j'allais dire comme un citoyen tout à
fait normal qu'ils aient un peu qui a
participé à l'élaboration des lois qui
sait pourquoi est-ce qu'on a souhaité
qu'il n'y ait pas plus de 7500 heureux
euros par e de dons annuels par personne
physique qui fait se donner un parti
politique par exemple je sais pourquoi
on l'a voulu et je m'interroge sur ce
que j'ai vu dans la comptabilité de ce
parti donc je ne porte aucune accusation
particules je ne fais qu observer les
choses et je souhaite que de donner
d'attirer l'attention parce
qu'effectivement voilà mon attrait
nature au cours des deux dernières
semaines sur ça pour que les choses mais
je dis quand ils disent que j'ai vu qu'
on ne peut pas laisser les choses sans
rien dire on a compris